is halloween ends really the end and why
does its star think the film will make
fans very angry here's all you need to
know before the big premiere
the official release date for halloween
ends is october 14th 2022 just in time
for the holiday filming for halloween
ends initially began in january 2022 and
concluded a few months later in march
pre-pandemic blumhouse studios had
planned to release halloween kills in
october 2020 and halloween ends one year
later in 2021 of course delays due to
kova 19 through a wrench into production
so the pair of sequels were pushed back
by ear studios generally like to release
halloween films well around halloween
which seems like a no-brainer you know
it's halloween i guess everyone's
entitled one good scare
this was the case for the first five
original halloween films which all
debuted theatrically in the month of
october the sixth just barely squeaked
in with a september 29th release date
this trend was surprisingly dropped in
favor of summer releases for halloween
h2o and halloween resurrection as well
as rob zombie's duo of reboots however
with the appearance of david gordon
green's new trilogy halloween has
returned to its classic fall schedule
with halloween ends wrapping up the
tradition by releasing around the same
time of year as its predecessors
the 2018 halloween film brought jamie
lee curtis back to the iconic role of
lori strode and introduced two new
generations in lori's daughter karen
played by judy greer and her
granddaughter allison played by andy
matacik though this central trio
survived that film and made it to the
climax of the follow-up halloween kills
ended on a shocking note as michael
murdered karen just before the credits
started so many people are dead we're
not equipped curtis and matacik are back
one last time in halloween ends with
james jude courtney and original actor
nick castle joining forces to bring
michael myers to life as they did on the
two previous entries kyle richards is
also back once again as lindsay wallace
laurie's 1978 babysitting charge who
managed to again narrowly escape
michael's knife in halloween kills
trilogy mainstays will patton and omar
dorsey round out the returning cast
members joining the cast is former
guiding light star michael o'leary as dr
mathis a character mentioned but not
seen in halloween kills rowan campbell
of hulu's the hearty boys will also
provide a fresh face as a new character
named corey cunningham
the official synopsis for halloween ends
explains that rather than picking up
exactly where we left off in halloween
kills the story will resume four years
later lori strode and her granddaughter
allison are living together and there's
no michael myers in sight we can assume
that the movie will have lori and
michael locked in a final showdown of
sorts at least a final showdown for this
iteration of the franchise as for the
fate of these two characters who can say
for certain in an interview with total
film magazine jamie lee curtis producer
malaika cod and director david gordon
green gave a few hints as to what
audiences might expect from the final
film in the trilogy after halloween
kills focused on the town of haddonfield
at large it seems like we're in for a
shift with a cod revealing that the
final film in the trilogy will be in his
words way more contained
it's disgusting
as for green he went on to elaborate
slightly suggesting that the final
halloween film which was originally
planned to take place on the same 2018
halloween night as both its predecessors
may be something fans won't expect he
told total film i get engaged by doing
something different if i was just going
to be repetitive i would hand the reins
off to someone else when you have that
opportunity within an established
franchise it's really fun to think about
how you can show different tones and
perspectives and evolve
the iconic not so sleepy town of
haddonfield illinois is one of the most
infamous movie towns in horror history
and also one of the deadliest while the
original john carpenter film was shot in
los angeles county the most recent
halloween trilogy traveled to the
opposite coast to film the 2018
halloween was mostly filmed in the low
country of south carolina the second
installment halloween kills was filmed
mostly in north carolina interestingly
halloween ends was shot primarily in and
around the savannah georgia area though
not exclusively according to the film's
imdb page photography for ends also took
place in part around salt lake city utah
a vast departure from the east coast
locations and the film's midwestern
setting leaving fans wondering just
where the final installment might take
us
the new halloween trilogy beginning with
the 2018 film is largely the brainchild
of filmmakers and long time
collaborators david gordon green and
danny mcbride though green and mcbride
were both new to the horror genre they
were long time fans of john carpenter
and deborah hill's original 1978
halloween and opted to ignore all the
previous sequels and remakes green went
on to direct all three films in this new
trilogy evidently even though they
ignored all the previous installments in
the franchise it still reportedly took
green and mcbride more than 80 drafts of
the screenplay to get it right with
rewrites happening as late as one week
before production according to the
hollywood reporter michael myers loose
with a bunch of nut bags and hadn't
failed on halloween night the duo of
green and mcbride returned to write the
screenplay for halloween kills alongside
scott teams resulting in a sequel that
proved more polarizing than its
crowd-pleasing predecessor green and
mcbride also co-wrote the screenplay for
halloween ends this time alongside paul
brad logan and chris bernier
when 2018's halloween was released it
was a simpler time the film arrived in
theaters and then quickly made its way
to home video soon after with the second
and third films in david gordon green's
planned trilogy being greenlit almost
immediately following its success
unfortunately it would be another three
years before halloween kills would be
released due to the coven 19 pandemic
with the sequel's initial release of
october 2020 being shifted to october
2021 halloween ends began filming not
long after the release of halloween
kills with a set release date for
october 2022 with only a year between
these two films green's two sequels will
follow an 80 slasher movie tradition of
immediate back-to-back entries the
earlier halloween series even
sporadically followed this pattern for a
while halloween 2 was released in
october 1981 continuing the story from
the first film with the largely
unrelated halloween 3 season of the
witch coming out a year later
in october 1988 halloween four the
return of michael myers was released
which brought myers back from his
comatose state leading into halloween
five the revenge of michael myers the
following october halloween ends is set
to arrive in theaters on october 14th
2022 and as with halloween kills before
it will also be made available on
peacock for the first 60 days of the
film's release the halloween franchise
is a bit complicated but most
long-running horror series are including
halloween ends there are 13 total films
in the saga though not all of them are
necessary to enjoy this final trilogy
installment the only movie in the
anthology that every film tends to stem
from is the original 1978 halloween
which introduced the world to both
michael myers and laurie strode this
masterpiece has become an icon over the
past four decades and no matter how many
new halloween sequels or reboots hit the
screen none can escape the shadow of the
original the original halloween 2
halloween 4 the return of michael myers
halloween 5 the revenge of michael myers
and halloween the curse of michael myers
all follow in the timeline begun with
the original the third installment
halloween three season of the witch has
nothing to do with the overall
continuity beyond the original movie
playing on tv within its story about
killer halloween masks then in 1998
halloween h2o 20 years later was
released to commemorate the anniversary
of the original halloween thus ignoring
all the sequels except halloween 2. this
film would spawn a sequel of its own
halloween resurrection which would soon
be ignored by rob zombie's two halloween
reboot films beginning in 2007. michael
you know i'm not really here halloween
ends fits in a timeline composed of the
original 1978 film the 2018 halloween
and halloween kills this effectively
sets aside all the convoluted sequel
plot threads concerning secret familial
relationships and ancient cults instead
focusing in on the pure slasher element
of an unknowable killer and his
tenacious prey
there's no doubt that david
gordon-green's take on the halloween
mythos isn't for everybody removing the
brother-sister connection between
michael myers and laurie strode was a
gutsy move especially given that the
vast majority of the franchise has kept
that part of their story intact this
makes sense given that john carpenter
himself made them siblings while working
on halloween 2 and the expanded tv
broadcast of the original film carpenter
admitted to comicbook.com in 2019 i came
up with this brother thing it was awful
just awful but i did it nevertheless the
2018 halloween revival disregarded this
plotline completely with carpenter's
blessing opting to start anew with only
the original 1978 film remaining a part
of the story this alone was frustrating
for some fans though for others it was a
new beginning and one that sparked new
life in an otherwise aimless franchise
according to series star jamie lee
curtis many fans might not love
halloween ends the final installment in
this rebooted trilogy of slashers she
told enemy it's going to make people
very angry and it's going to be shocking
because it asks a lot of questions so
that's all i can tell you wherever the
conclusion to this modern halloween
trilogy takes us it seems it will be
somewhere we've never gone before this
might be scary to some longtime michael
myers fans but the possibility of an
unprecedented and surprising conclusion
may be just the kind of uncertainty the
halloween franchise needs
for more than 40 years jamie lee curtis
has come and gone from her role as the
iconic final girl lori strode
continuously escaping the clutches of
michael myers now halloween ends
promises well an end to all that evil
dies tonight this means that either lori
is set to die in combat against michael
or live happily ever after once he's six
feet under whichever ending befalls our
horror heroine it will surely be
thrilling to see her story get a
definitive conclusion here jamie lee
curtis has implied in a video promoting
halloween ends that this is her last
time playing lori strode she went on to
explain to total film i'm not saying
something like oh because i die it's
nothing to do with that i'm talking
about emotionally what they've
constructed i think it will be a
spectacular way to end this trilogy
with a title like halloween ends there
are some pretty serious implications
attached no doubt this is the end to
david gordon green's sequel trilogy of
halloween films meant to be a love
letter of sorts to the original john
carpenter classic with jamie lee curtis
evidently satisfied with the film's
conclusion and the plot seemingly
wrapped up here it sounds like halloween
ends might actually be the final chapter
of the halloween saga and what better
film to end on than the 13th of course
john carpenter has his own thoughts on
the continuation of the halloween brand
carpenter told comicbook.com if you take
a dollar sign and attach it to anything
it will live if the dollar sign is not
big enough no matter what it will not
live this time i do not know they really
want to end they're going to shut it off
end it it's what david has in mind
that's fine in an interview with screen
rant producer jason blum went on record
and reminded us that this is blumhouse
productions last halloween movie and
while that doesn't necessarily mean that
michael myers won't return someday their
work on the franchise is complete blum
said this is our last one and i think
people will be very happy so it looks
like halloween ends is the culmination
of the franchise as we know it currently
but that doesn't mean it's the end for
halloween as a whole
[Music]
you